الخرطوم
من 17 سنه بها البلد حبينا السودان حبينا
اهل السودان
بين
فجاه
الحارس علينا وعلى الناس كلها
فعلا فعلا كانت
زي الزلزال سقطت على الناس كلها علينا نحن
بالاول كمان السودانيين
الخرطوم تركناها فعلا حزينه ما فيها ما
فيها حدا
لابنيه تبعنا للاستثمار تبعنا استثمارات
كثيره على الارض
تدمرت وطلعنا انا طلعت بهي الكنزه
بعد 17 سنه
او بلد زي السودان يحصل بلد النيلين يحصل
له اللي حصل
تبعت ايامها
تحت الضغط النفسي تحت
يعني
المرض خوفه من الاصابات من الخزائف من
والحمد لله يعني قدرنا
اخير انه املنا
اللبنانيه مثل ما كل الدول عم
لي ناسا
اليوم طلع
نا حضراتكم شايفين انه هلا رحنا كانت
دوله السعوديه تساعدنا كمان وننتقل عبر
الجده الى بلد
قله الاخيره هي فعلا انا حاطلع
بعيوني على هالب
لد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات